>> Marie: LIBERAL CITIES ARE
POINTING A FINGER AT
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR THE GROWING
HOMELESS CRISIS AND THAT COMES
AFTER TRUMP BLASTED CALIFORNIA
AND NEW YORK ON TWITTER AND SAID
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT MIGHT
HELP THE STATE LEADERS ASKED FOR
IT POLITELY.
NEW YORK CITY
MAYOR BILL de BLASIO RESPONDED
BY SAYING THIS.
>> THE PROBLEM ULTIMATELY IS
DONALD TRUMP HAS NOT SHOWN ANY
WILLINGNESS TO GIVE US THE TOOLS
THAT WE NEED MOST ESPECIALLY
SECTION 8 VOUCHERS WHICH ALLOW
PEOPLE TO LIVE IN RENTAL
HOUSING.
THAT'S THE SINGLE STRONGEST
PIECE WE NEED FROM WASHINGTON
THAT WE ARE NOT GETTING RIGHT
NOW.
>> MANY TIMES WE HAVE SEEN THE
HUD BUDGET IS ZEROED OUT, NO
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES.
>> IT'S RELATED TO HIGH ON
EMPLOYMENT RATES AND DRUG USE.
UNDER THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
WE HAVE THE LOWEST UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE AND YET YOU HAVE AT THE
LIBERAL MAYORS AND GOVERNORS
DECRIMINALIZING DRUG USE.
SO IS IT REALLY THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION NEEDS TO DO
SOMETHING OR THE LOCAL LAWMAKERS
NEED TO BE DOING SOMETHING?
>> THIS IS A LOCAL MATTER.
ALL THESE LOCALS SERIES HAVE
BEEN COVERING IT, AND WE'D SEEN
IT JACKED UP BEFORE DONALD TRUMP
AND THE CITY WON'T TAKE MATTERS
INTO THEIR OWN HANDS.
IT'S DECIMATED MY COMMUNITY, AN
AND, THEY ARE REQUESTING MORE
THAN TO SECTION 8 FUNDING.
>> NO ONE KNOWS WHAT THEY
LONG-TERM STRATEGY IS.
IT'S A HUGE PROBLEM, IT ISN'T AN
EPIDEMIC IN SOME OF THESE PLACES
AND IT IS HEARTBREAKING.
I DON'T KNOW QUITE FRANKLY, I
DON'T KNOW THE POLICY LEVEL IS.
I REACT SO NEGATIVELY TO THE WAY
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THE LANGUAGE
HE USES TO TALK ABOUT THE
HOMELESS PROBLEM, I KNOW WE SAY
THIS A LOT ABOUT THEM BUT THESE
ARE PEOPLE, THESE ARE HUMANS AND
THE WAY HE TALKS ABOUT IT AND
USES IT TO GO AFTER SOME OF HIS
POLITICAL RIVALS, IT'S NOT
HELPING SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
IT JUST FEELS SO HEARTLESS.
YOU SEE PEOPLE WHO CAN'T FIND A
PLACE TO LIVE AND I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE ANSWER IS.
AND NOW TOM, LAST YEAR THE
LIBERAL NINTH CIRCUIT RULE TO
RESTRICT THE ABILITY TO ACTUALLY
CLEAR HOMELESS ENCAMPMENTS AND
THAT IS NOW MAKING BUSINESSES
LEAVE THESE AREAS.
THAT CAN'T BE GOOD FOR THE
LONG-TERM CITIES.
>> THAT'S WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS DOING, HE'S NOT BEING
HEARTLESS BUT HE'S TEASING
MAYORS LIKE BILL de BLASIO WHO
HAVE FAILED POLICIES.
MOST AMERICANS HEAR THAT AND
THEY SAY WHAT IS THIS GUY
GOVERNING?
AMERICA'S BIGGEST CITY?
IT'S OLD SCHOOL, BAD, IT'S
FAILED AND DOESN'T WORK.
>> THE CYCLE OF POVERTY.
>> THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT NEEDS
TO BE DOING SOMETHING BUT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS WANTING TO
MAKE TIGHTER IMMIGRATION
CONTROL.
HOWEVER CALIFORNIA RECEIVES ALL
OF THAT.
AND HOW CAN THEY SAY THAT THEY
NEED FEDERAL HELP OR THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS NOT DOING
ENOUGH WHEN THEY ARE REJECTING
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
TRYING TO DO FOR THE HOMELESS
CRISIS.
>> RIGHT, AND WHAT I'M HEARING
IS AN APT STATEMENT THAT IS
CALIFORNIA AND A LOT OF
DEMOCRATIC RUNS, CITIES AND
STATES, THEY ARE SENDING
HISTORIC AMOUNTS AND HOMELESS
STATISTICS ARE ALSO HISTORICALLY
SPIKING.
THE INVESTMENT IS MADE, IT'S A
50% DECREASE IN HOMELESSNESS AND
VETERANS.
HE IS PURSING HIS FACTS BECAUSE,
THEY ARE SPIKING IN THOSE CITIES
INCLUDING HIS -- IN
SAN FRANCISCO WHEN HE WAS MAYOR.
THEY ARE OBSESSED WITH TOUTING
HIS OWN ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
AND IN TERMS OF WHAT YOU AGREE
WITH, I THINK IT'S A WAR OF
COMPASSION WHICH IS CRIPPLING.
PEOPLE ON THE LEFT IN TERMS OF
THEIR APPROACH TO THIS WHICH IS
WHY THERE'S A FAILURE TO ACCOUNT
FOR ALL THOSE FACTORS LIKE DRUG
ADDICTION, UNTIL ILLNESS AND THE
LIKE.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT UNITS.
>> A HUGE NUMBER OF THE HOMELESS
ARE ON DRUGS OR ADDICTED TO
DRUGS AS WELL.
THAT'S NOT IT.
THEY WILL NOT BE FUNCTIONING
MEMBERS OF SOCIETY AND WE HAVE
TO COME TOGETHER IN A
MULTIFACETED APPROACH.
I THINK THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAS
A LOT MORE THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE